hey guys it is the 7th of December my
name is Jess and here's some of the big
things that happened in gaming today
first up PlayStation worldwide studios
president Shuhei Tschida has commented
on the Nintendo switch you see the told
Digital Spy it's very interesting that
they've designed the system to work well
with the more conventional games in
terms of inputs and buttons so I think
it's good for core gamers and their
marketing message focused on that when
asked whether Sony sees Nintendo as a
competitor in the hardware space ueshiba
said I think they're going to cover a
new market for themselves in others
which related news Eurogamer has
reported that the console can play
GameCube games through its virtual
console program reportedly there are
already three Nintendo published
GameCube games in the pipeline Super
Mario Sunshine Luigi's Mansion and super
smash brothers melee it's claimed that
there will also be an upgrade program
where people who bought games by the
Virtual Console can upgrade them to the
new hardware for a small price Final
Fantasy 15 game director Hajime Tabata
has revealed a bunch of free updates
that are coming to the game in a blog
post
Tabata said we want you to enjoy Final
Fantasy 15 for a long time to come we've
been listening to your ideas on how to
make the game experience even better and
so in addition to the previously
announced content we'll be providing
free updates to the game throughout the
coming year
Square Enix said the plan is to enrich
certain aspects of the game
apply gameplay enhancements for chapter
13 as well as buffs to bring magic among
other things the studio will then be
adding more scenes and sequences to
Final Fantasy 15 story
Tabata explained we're hoping to delve
deeper into the story adding scenes that
will give you insight into character
motivations such as why Ravis walked the
path he did we will need a little time
with these as they'll need to be
localized and voiced in other languages
I will let you know the details once
everything is set Tabata said the studio
also want to introduce customizable
avatars stats that carry over from
previous playthroughs new bosses and UI
tweaks among other things for the full
list of everything coming to Final
Fantasy 15 ahead to our story on game
but finally a new Pokemon go update is
that today and here's what it does the
latest patch introduces the ability for
players to transfer multiple pokemons
simultaneously to professor willow
finally if you want to do this just
press and hold on a Pokemon the update
also adds icons for Pokemon typed to the
gym battle approach and gym battle
screens while the total candy count the
Buddy Pokemon is added to the Buddy
information screen that also now
includes the total distance that a Buddy
Pokemon has what Niantic will also
announce what new pokemon will be coming
to pokemon go on December 12 let me know
in the comments what you cared about
today head to GameSpot for halo 5 Forge
news and I'll see you again tomorrow